WWDC 2019 oh my goodness
[Music]
this keynote was so insane sitting there
in the audience and trying to take
pictures as things just flew by it was
almost impossible like things were
happening so quickly first of all the
shock to me was the fact that they
announced a MacPro what of all the
things that I predicted that was one of
the things that I predicted them to
never do what they did I'm so excited
because we got a chance to see it not
only do we get a chance to see than that
Pro also got to see the new displays
they announced being able to see it up
close in person like it really was wow
this is the first 32 inch a 6 km Retina
display this obviously easy to display
for everyone and this is geared towards
the professionals I still would like to
consider myself a professional with the
amount of video that I edit is probably
a lot more than some people would ever
really imagine so for me this is
something that I definitely would invest
in although I'm not coloring feature
films or anything crazy like that it is
really great you go to see those four
colors and sing this thing a pulse it
definitely makes me want to step up my
game and I think it may be time to start
shooting in 8k because now with this Mac
Pro it is so powerful that editing aka
footage is just gonna be like editing
720p footage on my macbook pro it's
gonna be like don't worry we've got this
for editing they announced this graphics
accelerator called the afterburner so
with this thing installed in Final Cut
you would have three streams of aka Pro
res raw footage 12 streams of 4k Pro res
footage and up to 16 streams of 4k Pro
res that's so amazing and I'm definitely
not creating anything here on YouTube
right now that would call for that but
again maybe I need to there's also this
really cool 8k workflow that they had in
this little hands-on demo station
they're taking this footage sending it
over here compositing it and then we
have over here another workflow to go
into the editing and
over here we fetch a colouring station
so obviously the Mac Pro and the
displays were incredible highlight for a
lot of people but they also announced so
many other things in the software realm
like iOS 13 finally I mean we've been
talking about this for a while and a lot
of the things that I predicted and a lot
of things that the internet predicted
yes it came true and number one being
dark mode I mean look at this it looks
so great I know it's not new technology
and it's not a new feature it's kind of
great that Apple has finally caught up
to that trend from like the text
messages like look how great that looks
after using the dark mode of Mohave like
this is something that I'm so glad that
they finally have Iowa's 13 will have a
30% faster face ID at recognition so
that's a plus and we were to launch apps
two times faster man there are so many
things oh this is really cool Siri
now has a new voice using this neuro
text-to-speech so they showed a really
cool example on stage of what she
sounded like before but here's one that
she sounded like after cuz I kind of
forgot to film her before but you guys
all know what Siri sounds like but this
is what she can sound like in iOS 13
absolute zero is the lowest limit of the
thermodynamic temperature scale estate
at which the enthalpy and entropy of a
cooled ideal gas reach their minimum
value taken as zero Apple sign-in you
guys always see these things all over
the internet where it's like okay sign
in with your Google profile sign in with
your Facebook and all of that is is
collecting your data privacy is such a
huge concern and it's really great to
see that Apple takes that seriously so
this is pretty neat you can sign in
using your Apple ID now what they will
also do is they will give you the option
because a lot of these sites need your
email address you can say no I don't
want to give you my email address and
athlete will create one in the cloud for
you and that will then forward to your
email address and you'll be able to make
new email addresses for every single
site that you sign up with but they
won't actually have a real email address
I love this so watch that I'm thinking
about going and unsign you up for
everything that I've ever signed up for
Andry signing in with my Apple ID that
sounds actually like a lot of work so
probably won't do that but from now on
Apple sign-in that's the way to go I'm
excited to see who actually starts
adopting this which I feel like people
are gonna crazy not to some people might
be a little bit upset with that like
companies because you're not gonna be
actually getting people's data anymore
so I feel like there may be a slow
adoption for that most
just because those companies want all of
our information and apples not going to
give it to him they're talking about
homekit cameras so securing your cameras
and security footage I was hoping that
they were gonna actually announced a
homekit security camera made by Apple
and they didn't so I was talking about
homekit enabled routers so those will be
coming out sometime in the fall I
believe and they also said that spectrum
was on board so that'll be coming
directly from your cable company new
MIMO G accessories I think this is
definitely something that I predicted I
did predict they were going to have them
be a micro transaction so thank you for
not making us pay for these what's cool
about this is you can take your Mii
emojis and you can turn them into actual
emojis I love emojis so this is
something that I'm excited about maybe
new Photos app so they have this new
layout for photos so you can have it
organized between day month year and
it's cool because they will take a
little snapshot of your day so they
won't show you all of the photos but
they will make it all nicely laid out so
you can get a better shot of the good
shots that you shot that day so I take
so many videos and pictures mostly of my
dog it's a little be great to kind of
have a little snapshot of those they
also updated the photo editing I really
liked the photo editing in here already
so since they're taking that same tech
and kind of making it better that's
gonna be really cool to play around with
but in the demo that they showed here it
all looked like it worked pretty well
also really excited to be able to edit
video a little bit easier you can add
filters and you can also rotate the
video I've been waiting for that for so
long like I don't know why that is such
a simple thing that it took them that
long to do but it doesn't matter it's
here I was 13 done - done you can rotate
video you can pinch-to-zoom Jenna's in
the bathroom right now because I'm
shooting this video she's hiding this
looks like a really professional
production here and she's actually
editing on the toilet like I need to
show you what this looks like right now
you're not gonna believe me
you's need a MacPro now yep oh my gosh
that'd be great we'll fit perfect okay
bye anyway where did I leave off Jenna
editing in the bathroom there's also it
update to air pods so when I was 13
you'll be able to share the same audio
stream much like those headphone
splitters in the past that I'm sure all
of you have seen and have used you can
use two pairs of ear pods and listen to
the same thing at the same time also be
doing an update to Apple maps of making
everything much higher quality there's
also this really cool feature called the
look around and as you're looking around
you can click on buildings or different
establishments and you can add those to
collections or favorites for things that
you may want to visit in the future I
was hoping for some more updates to home
pod but there really wasn't much the
main thing that they did say that will
be in iOS 13 and in the latest home pod
update is home pod will be able to
recognize different voices so if for
instance I go in and tell home pod to
play me some music it will know to play
music that I like if my sister goes it
it says play me some music will play her
some music it'll play music that she
likes I think having a multi-user home
pod experience is something that you're
gonna have to have in the future because
having just one device and many people
using it that'll completely throw off
your algorithm as you guys know I love
my Apple watch so much so there were
some updates to watch OS 6 that are
gonna be really fun and for me as a
woman and other ladies out there who
have to deal with that monthly visitor
there's a new cycles app so not only
will you be able to track your menstrual
cycle on your Apple watch it will also
carry over into the healthkit app so
even if you don't have an Apple watch
this is something that you can use on
your phone as well hey now to send you
watch faces it look pretty awesome I
love the gradient one so you'll be able
to customize that to any color so it can
match your Apple watch bands it was also
some new Apple watch bands that they
announced I didn't really get a chance
to look at them too closely because I
kind of brushed past it pretty fast
there was a pink one and you know what I
will be getting there's now an
audiobooks app there's a calculator app
and voice memos I don't really use voice
memos that often but I do a lot of
people that do so having that accessible
just right on your wrist at any time is
really cool it'll then sync to your
phone voice memos so it'll be super
seamless they also announced the app
watch app store so you'll be able to
download apps directly from the watch OS
store on your wrist
you won't need a phone or any
they'll separate you can just do
everything right here be able to updated
the watch activity that also transfers
over to your phone they have activity
trends so all of the activity data that
I have on my watch from the past several
years it's kind of insane because it'll
be able to take all of that and I'll be
able to analyze the data from the past
90 days and tell me how I'm doing so
using those different kinds of trends
it'll be able to say hey you were doing
a little bit better 90 days ago which
yes
I know I was but now I actually have
that data right in front of me to make
me feel worse well the fact that I
haven't working out as much as I'd like
it also announced iPad OS which this
brings is so much more functionality to
the iPad so we did get a chance to check
out some of the features here on iPad OS
and it's really cool because you can see
here you can have all of these different
slide over features so you can rotate
through Windows very easily and also
added some new gestures so there's the
new copy and paste gestures tool copy
you just kind of do a three finger pinch
and then to paste it you do the same
things it's kind of like you're throwing
it down the page and then if you want to
undo and redo so it's just three fingers
swipe to the left three fingers swipe to
the right that's so much easier than
shaking your iPad to undo its of a new
cursors if you're trying to select text
you will actually have a cursor on the
screen so you'll be able to see what
you're doing so if you want to copy text
this makes it so much easier to see what
you're actually selecting Apple pencil
latency is now being reduced from 20
milliseconds to nine milliseconds I
don't really draw or do that much with
my have a pencil so that's a pretty
significant decrease if you ask me
although we're talking about a single
side call right now use your iPad as a
second display this is really great
because I travel a lot and I edit a lot
of footage on the go I'm able to have
that second display - maybe just
organize footage or anything it's got a
really cool you don't use the iPad as a
tablet which it yes it is a tablet if
you're using Photoshop or illustrator or
whatever it is that you're doing you
would actually go in and even illustrate
on it so this is a cool example this is
showing you're illustrating in
Illustrator using
the iPad as a display they also made an
update to the files app which is
something that really desperately was
needed it's also cool because if you are
using this on the iPad you can have SD
card and USB support if you have a flash
drive with some photos you can plug that
in and those will automatically be
imported into the files app so you can
just open it up and see what's on the
card it also showed a little demo of if
you have a camera you can plug it in
using USB C to your iPad and get those
photos directly off of the camera and
import them right into Lightroom this is
going to be really great because you can
use all of your Lightroom presets and
just have everything right there
automatically on your iPad they talked a
little bit also about Apple TV and
having Apple TV across all platforms is
really great
being able to watch Apple TV on your Mac
that's gonna be really cool especially
with the Apple TV plus they did show a
trailer of one of their shows called for
all mankind I was happy that they were
gonna show a little bit more about some
of the shows that they were working on
but I figure they'll probably have an
entire separate event for that and I had
so much stuff to cover in this there
probably wasn't time one of the saddest
things but we all knew that was gonna
happen eventually is the death of iTunes
itunes is no more it was now replaced by
three separate apps TV music and
podcasts oh they also showed this really
great example of being able to search
podcasts and not just search the titles
of podcasts or the description but
actually search the things that people
are talking about in podcast there's
ever 700,000 podcasts in the podcast
store which is kind of crazy to think
because that is now all searchable so
you want to search for anything you can
throw so now bringing screen time to Mac
so you'll be able to know how much time
you spend doing what on your Mac there
also and have this really cool thing
called activation lock so if you do buy
some really awful chance lose your
computer or someone steals it you'll be
able to add an activation lock so no one
will be able to reset that computer
unless they have your iCloud account and
password they also talked about the new
find my app do you want to find your
iPhone or your Mac now and it doesn't
have to be connected to Wi-Fi so using
bluetooth and using other devices around
it it'll be able to triangulate where
that item is so we're about to try out
some of the new AR demos and right now
marques and I are gonna
this game called swift strike and they
asked who was gonna win I said I'm not
competitive so we'll see what happens
[Applause]
with the three those can be a person
inclusion so you'll be able to put
yourself into these augmented reality
environments they also showed a really
cool demo of motion capture you'll be
able to mocap yourself it's just crazy
to see how far technology has come with
these things it once could only be done
in crazy Hollywood film studios you're
able to do on a phone in the palm of
your hand well there's so much more than
I'm going to talk about but I really
want to try to get this video out
quickly for you guys this day it was
just overwhelming we saw so many great
things especially with the announcement
the Mac Pro I will probably be talking
more about that in a later video but for
now I just want to know what did you
guys think what was your favorite part
what do you guys think of the Mac Pro
what are you they go display what do you
think of all of the iOS updates leave
all of those in the comments below and I
will see you in the next
[Music]